these are the 13 moments the Demon
Slayer story just didn't make any sense
and let's start with this one where
Tundra literally did something
impossible during his fight with a swamp
demon after some battling Tantra
eventually ends up in a swamp and is
unable to breathe so what does he do
next he breathes yeah that's right
inside of a muddy swamp Tantra somehow
manages to breathe and perform a
breathing technique I mean look I know
tantra's sense of smell is comical
sometimes but come on breathing
underwater really the plot holes
throughout the video are only going to
get more and more crazier from here and
some of them later on completely changed
the direction of the story anyway let's
continue with this one during tantra's
fight against doci in season 2 at one
point he manages to cut off her leg
however when Doki regenerates something
weird happens instead of just
regenerating her flesh like any other
demon she somehow regenerates a part of
her outfit as well I mean it's not
really a groundbreaking plot hole but
it's pretty interesting but definitely
not as interesting as this one about
previous water hashira it's a konji so
you all know how sukunji's top Tundra
how to use water breathing nothing
unusual with that but he also did
something else that was quite
fascinating he managed to hypnotize
nezuko to see all humans as her family
and to suppress her demonic urges
although this is something you most
likely didn't think too much about I
can't help but wonder how on Earth did
he pull that off I mean in the entire
series we've never seen anyone else
doing something like this so did
yurokodakis have some special psychic
abilities what's even weirder is that
this was never mentioned again during
the course of the series I guess that we
should just forget this ever happened in
season 3 of Demon Slayer we were
introduced to swordsmith Village and we
learned just how hard it is to get there
first you must get blindfolded and then
someone will carry you there so you
don't know where you're going but even
the people who carry Slayers don't know
where the village is they follow a bunch
of different crows for days until they
get there anyway the point is the
village is super well hidden so how did
gyoko manage to find it it's surely
explained somewhere right no we
literally watched two full minutes of
detailed explanation of how well the
village is hidden just so Kyoko can
mysteriously find it moments later this
just makes The Village's whole top
secret status seemed like a joke there
was another thing that didn't make sense
in season one specifically during the
final selection you see while Tundra was
trying to survive in the woods in order
to become a Demon Slayer we learned that
this huge demon lived there for a long
time and was way stronger than any demon
in there should be so my question is how
didn't the gore know about it this demon
was there for at least 30 years and in
all this time nobody who passed the
final selection said anything to the
core like hey guys there's a demon down
there who is like too strong you should
check it out I mean I agree that Tantra
killing it was way more satisfying but
come on this doesn't make any sense okay
you all know how tantro trained really
hard to cut this Boulder in half but
fortunately he had someone to help him
out sabito and macomo who were well
ghosts anyway since this is a Shonen
anime Let's ignore the Ghost part for
now as it's pretty usual for these types
of shows however the important question
I have to ask her is how in the hell did
the ghost manage to inflict visible
physical damage to tanjaro check out
this scene right after sabito knocks
hondro out it's clear that Tantra is
injured from the attack and is even
bleeding I guess we shouldn't think
about this scene that much we still have
six plot holes left to cover and these
next ones will definitely blow your mind
for example take a look at this one
regarding nezuko she went from being a
Charming teenage girl to a demon forced
to live in a box but some things about
her demonic nature don't make much sense
for example why did she go from being
intelligent to having the mind of a
toddler or why did she lose her ability
to speak you could say that a demon
transformation made her that way but so
far in the series we've never seen a
demon with these symptoms even much
weaker demons than her are capable of
thinking and talking so why is she an
exception and yeah I know she talks a
bit later on in the manga but why wait
so long didn't she want to say something
to her brother during all those years
there is another character that chose
not to tell anything to Tundra and it is
Tamayo okay let me explain at the
beginning of the show we didn't know
much about tomayo so her conversation
with Tundra seemed pretty normal however
after reading through the whole manga
and learning who she really is there are
a few things that don't add up since
tomayo lived during urichi's era she
must have known about Sun breathing in
Demon Slayer marks but for some reason
she chose not to reveal any of this to
tanjaro some of you may say that she
didn't remember it since it was a long
ago but come on tanjaro and yurishi
literally have the exact same earrings
and Demon Slayer marks there's no way
she didn't notice that she was also
muzon's close servant and probably knew
much information about him that she
could share as well but she didn't this
really makes you wonder if her backstory
was planned from the beginning were just
added later speaking of first meetings
let's talk about the one between muzon
and Tundra when the two first met things
went weird for some reason muzan didn't
even attempt to attack the boy and
instead turned this random guy into a
demon and then just casually walked away
do you see any problem with this okay
let me help you out with that despite
his cover being blown by a demon Slayer
despite that Slayer having the same Mark
as yurishi and despite seeing the
earrings worn by a man who almost killed
him the best he could do is just walk
away you may say he didn't want other
people to see who he really was but that
also makes zero sense he's a demon king
if he wanted to he could
group of people around tundra in second
and nobody would know what happened
but no I guess just casually walking
away would make much more sense right
but did you know that there is a huge
huge plot hole in inosuke's backstory
you all know Haley was raised by the
boars and trained by himself in the
wilderness nothing wrong with that but
there is one little detail pretty much
nobody noticed how the hell did a nosuke
manage to develop his breathing style it
was clearly stated in the manga that
anosuke had no teacher and that he
taught himself this breathing style
while fighting for survival in the
mountains but do you see a problem with
this explanation the only guy in the
entire series that managed to learn a
breathing Style by himself is yorichi
sugikuni the guy who invented them is
the show implying that inosuke is just
as talented as yorishi I mean it's
either that or the boars taught him
before we cover the absolute biggest
plot hole in the entire Demon Slayer we
first need to talk about Wisteria poison
out of all the Slayers in the show
shinobu is the only character using this
poison during combat although this makes
sense considering her medical background
and status as the insect to Shira I just
can't help but wonder why are the other
demon Slayers using it in their battles
there are literally no downsides to this
they can all still continue to use their
normal weapons and just lace them with
poison this would instantly make them
many times more powerful as they could
paralyze demons just by touching them
with their swords even the upper Moon
six youthrow was greatly weakened for a
short time when tandro stabbed him with
wisteria kunai so just imagine if every
Slayer could paralyze a demon like that
it would make their job so much easier
another thing they could do is make
long-range weapons something like bows
or guns lace bullets with wisteria and
use them to fight demons from a distance
the possibilities here are endless and
who knows if the Slayers utilize this
simple trick maybe rangoku would survive
his battle against akaza and finally
let's talk about the biggest plot hole
in the show throughout his life muzon
had only one goal to find a blue Spider
Lily and get immunity to sunlight
however no matter how hard he looked he
could never find this mysterious flower
not even after 1 000 years of searching
the explanation for this can be found in
chapter 205 where it was revealed that
the flower only blooms for a few days
every year and only during sunlight but
again like with all the plot holes so
far this just doesn't make any sense is
the show trying to tell us that in over
a thousand years of searching muzon
didn't attempt to gather information
from humans what about the countless
people he consumed did none of them have
any memories of seeing the flower what
about all the other demons in the world
are we really supposed to believe that
none of them tried to make humans look
for the flower during the day the entire
Army of demons searched 1 000 years for
this thing and the explanation we get is
oh it only blooms during the day so
muzon never found it it makes no sense
click on this video where we explained
all eight Demon Slayer gods in Demon
Slayer